so if you've been training for any
significant amount of time then you will
at some point ever run into a plateau
things have been progressing nicely and
then at some point the gains just stop
coming you stop seeing progress you
can't lift more than that weight or you
just can't seem to get the planche
that's me by the way you'd hit a dead
end and it really sucks what's going on
if you hit your limits should you just
give up the answer to whether or not you
should give up is of course a resounding
no plateaus are not only normal but may
in fact be essential to your overall
progress and gains because in fact it
might not really be a plateau at all you
might be progressing just not in a way
that you can see or that you can measure
see all the adaptations you go through
in response to training are forms of
plasticity neural plasticity muscle
plasticity and motor unit plasticity
neuroplasticity is the ability for your
brain to form new connections and that
can then help you to learn new skills
motor unit plasticity is the ability of
your peripheral nervous system to
recruit more motor units in your muscles
in accordance with those patterns in
your brain and thereby perform the
movement more perfectly or with more
power it's this in conjunction with
hypertrophy and increase the muscle
fiber thickness increased fast twitch
muscle fiber count that helps us to
eventually master those skills or bust
through those plateaus but this is where
we see the necessary role of plateaus
according to the excellent book the
brain that changes itself whenever we
learn any new skill through plasticity
it's normal for there to be a process of
progression and then a normal
consolidation period where we might not
see any obvious change that's because
first we form the new connections and
then the brain needs to cement those
connections it needs to strengthen them
and strengthen those networks so that
it's more easy to access them in future
then more neural branching needs to
occur to create more new connections but
it's not until those connectors are
actually fully formed that we then see
the new skill or the increased strength
emerge repeating the same feat over and
over again even when you're not seeing
yourself get any better at it will get
any stronger increases myelination of
existing networks and long-term
potentiation making it easier fees to
perform those more in future so in other
words progression isn't always linear it
doesn't matter if it's not a straight
upwards curve and this doesn't ring true
when I watch my six month old girl Emme
develop a new skill such as rolling or
crawl
which she hasn't quite mastered yet at
first we'll see I get closer and closer
she'll roll more and more onto one side
she'll seemingly be this close to
getting it and then she'll stop she'll
plateau she couldn't get that arm out
the way in the case of rolling and she
kept rolling onto it and it looked like
she wasn't gonna get anywhere then one
day out of the blue she did well over
and now she does it all the time
and now she's building towards the next
skill which is crawling and the same
thing happens when I'm practicing my
calisthenics for ages it seems like
nothing's gonna happen then click
suddenly one day I perform the move for
the very first time and it's an amazing
feeling that amazing feeling by the way
that's the Reese of chemicals that
actually strengthen that connection even
further so what do we take from all this
first of all don't give up even when you
stop seeing progress you're still
actually improving you just can't
measure it keep at it
focus on those skills keep greasing the
groove this could also make a case for
soup for a maximal training which is an
awesome word which basically means
tricking yourself or forcing yourself
into performing movements or lifts that
you otherwise wouldn't normally be able
to so in the case of plants you might
mean swinging your legs into that
position and trying to hold yourself
there for as long as possible in the
case of a 1 rep max might mean using
heavy partials or slow negatives all
these things will help to light up the
right areas of the brain the right
recruitment pattern in the muscles and
then it's just a matter of getting there
again and repeating it in order to
consolidate and form those connections
over time another thing to try is
something that I've just made up called
spaced training so this is a riff on
space 2 learning which was discovered by
neuroscientist Paul Kelly this is a
technique that's used for rote
memorization of information and learning
other these skills and abilities
basically involves small dense periods
of learning interspersed with strategic
breaks 10 minutes long is apparently the
correct temporal code in other words
instead of learning something all in one
go and consistently you're in fact
breaking up into lots of small learning
sessions and this has been shown to
improve recall and helps to learn things
more quickly and there's lots of
theories as to why this might be but it
likely has to do with potentiation those
brain areas those connections have time
to cool off so that instead of just
using them consistently you're using
them again and thereby reinforcing that
connection so if we apply this idea to
training then when performing something
heavy or something new you might have
one go at it but without exhausting
yourself and then have a 10-minute break
and come back and do it again I haven't
actually experimented with this
theory but thought I'd share it because
it was interesting and I'll be trying it
so let you know how I get on with it in
future but the main takeaway plateauing
doesn't necessarily mean not progressing
not all progress is forwards so keep at
it
good luck you'll get there in the end
the thanks a ton for watching guys hope
fans somebody useful and interesting if
you did then please leave a like please
share it around that helps me out
immensely I love this sort of thing
because it combines my interests in the
brain and neuroscience with fitness and
training let me know if you have any
other similar tips or any other areas
that you'd like me to delve into in
future videos got a lots more on the way
as always the Nightwing video is on the
way soon I'm gonna be showing my own
training program and we're on the way to
hundreds of subscribers when we finally
get there I'm going to be sharing
hopefully some cool new announcements
some really interesting changes for the
channel so if that sounds good
then thanks a ton for watching and I'll
see you next time bye for now